Trường ngày 8 mẹ thành chiến tại mỗi tiếp súc cụ chỉ đơn vị mộ cụ số mời,
hà nội trước khi họ tử mời của hội khoảng 1 năm.
Tổn bị thư tổn lâm cho biết năm 2019,
sự kiến khoảng thành 1 năm trên 15 tri tiêu phát triển kinh tế,
sau hội.
Thương ngân sách đến quой thành chiến đã đặt kế hoạch cả năm,
cả 1 2 triệu tì đồng có thể lên đầu đặt 2.5 triệu tì đồng.
Những mạnh quan điểm lấy nhân dân làm chung tâm,
tổn bị thư nêu yêu cầu điều trình chính sách tìl lương,
chự cấp sau hội.
Sông cải cách tìl lương phải gắn tinh dản biên trẻ trên cơ sở nân cao năng xuất lào động,
sau định vị trí việc làm theo mô hình tổ chức mối,
bảo đam năng mức sống người hưởng lương và giám chi thử xin.
Về ý tế, thực hiện nghị quyết 12,
trên mạnh sàng phòng bệnh khám xúc khoảng định kì hàng năm,
hương tối miến,
giám viện phi qua mở giống phạm vi bao hiểm ý tế,
kiểm soát dự miệng, thuốc lá, ô nhiễm, an toàn thực phẩm.
Về giáo dục, nghiên cứu phục cập chung học phổ thông,
niễn học phi và bảo đam đủ chương, đủ thầy.